Profª. Tamar Gendler: OK, então o que
eu quero fazer hoje é terminar
a aula da semana passada
sobre utilitarismo
e, em seguida, passar para
o que é, talvez,
a principal aula dos
caras-mortos-na-terça-feira do
semestre;
ou seja, uma explicação sobre a
filosofia de Immanuel Kant.
Portanto, para compensar o fato
de que a 2ª parte da aula
é bastante seca,
vamos dispor de umas perguntas
com clicker na 1ª parte.
OK, então como vocês se lembram
da nossa última aula aula,
John Stuart Mill, em
trechos do Utilitarismo,
diz 2 coisas notórias que
servem em alguns aspectos
como o coração da
percepção utilitarista.
A 1ª é uma exposição conhecida
como o princípio da maior felicidade.
É um princípio que intenciona dizer
o que é preciso para um ato
ser moralmente correto.
E o que Mill aponta é que há
uma proporcionalidade
entre a retidão do ato e
algo produzido por ele.
Em especial, uma proporcionalidade
entre a retidão do ato e a quantidade
de bem-estar que ele produz,
independentemente de como o
bem-estar é distribuído.
Em especial, ele afirma que as
ações são corretas
na proporção em que elas tendem
a promover o bem-estar
e que são erradas quando tendem
a promover o seu oposto;
e o bem-estar que está em causa
não é o bem-estar do agente,
mas de todos os envolvidos.
A 2ª frase extraordinariamente
notória nas passagens de abertura
do Utilitarismo é que o
motivo com que um ato
é realizado é irrelevante para
o valor moral do ato.
Ele diz que o motivo não tem nada a
ver com a moralidade da ação.
"Aquele que salva um
semelhante de se afogar
faz o que está moralmente certo
seja o seu motivo o dever,
seja a esperança de ser pago."
Assim, poderíamos resumir o que
dizem esses princípios,
comentando que o 1º diz que o que
importa para a moralidade
de um ato é o valor total de
bem-estar que ele produz.
E estamos interessados aqui no
coletivo, não nos indivíduos.
Estamos interessados ??na
quantidade de bem feito em geral,
e não onde atuam os pedaços do bem.
E o que o 2º princípio diz
é que o utilitário,
que é, afinal, um consequencialista,
está interessado nas consequências.
Ele está interessado ?no
resultado do ato,
não no processo pelo qual se
chegou ao resultado.
Assim, a 1ª leitura feita para a
última aula foi uma seleção
do Utilitarismo de Mill, onde ele
articula esses princípios.
E é importante reconhecer que
alcançamos algo profundamente
certo sobre o que estamos refletindo
quando tentamos articular
o que está por trás dos
nossos julgamentos morais.
Parece claro que o nosso
interesse reside em como o mundo
é após uma determinada ação e,
na medida em que nos interessa
saber como o mundo é,
nosso principal interesse
não está na forma como esse
estado de coisas surgiu,
mas o que é esse estado de coisas.
E a nossa principal preocupação,
se estamos tomando uma posição moral,
não é com quanto nós mesmos temos,
mas sim com quanto de bem
existe no mundo em geral.
Dito isso, desde que o
utilitarismo foi articulado,
tem sido trazido à tona um
conjunto clássico de objeções,
algumas das quais falaremos mais
hoje e outras encontramos
nos trechos de Bernard Williams
lidos na última aula.
Todos vocês se lembram que a
discussão de Williams
começa com a história de um
homem chamado Jim,
que está numa aldeia sul-americana
governada por um líder desagradável.
E alguns dos habitantes da aldeia
têm questionado a liderança do
líder desagradável.
E, então, o líder desagradável
reúne 20 moradores insurgentes
e planeja matá-los
– simplesmente para mostrar aos
outros que ele está no comando.
Quando Jim chega, o governante Pedro
comenta que se Jim está disposto a
atirar em 1 dos aldeões,
os outros 19 serão libertados.
Então esta é a situação de Jim.
Jim aparece numa cidade.
O chefão da cidade selecionou
20 pessoas ao acaso para disparar,
mas se Jim está disposto a matar 1 delas,
as outras 19 serão libertadas...
Portanto, saquem os clickers.
Questão: No caso de Jim, o que Jim
está moralmente obrigado a fazer?
A coisa moral para Jim fazer neste
caso é atirar em 1 homem,
libertando assim os outros 19,
ou a coisa certa é se
recusar a atirar em 1,
deixando todos os 20 morrerem?
OK, então vamos ver os
números que saem.
Portanto, quase 3/4 de vocês, na
verdade, mais de 3/4 de vocês
acham que o que a coisa moralmente
certa para Jim fazer neste
caso é atirar em 1 homem,
libertando os outros 19.
Nós vamos ter a chance de falar mais
sobre esses tipos de
perguntas na semana que vem.
A nossa leitura para quinta
é uma série de dilemas morais
com esta mesma estrutura.
Mas o que eu quero pedir agora, aos
77% que responderam "sim",
é para pensarem
se o que Williams diz é naturalmente
o próximo passo utilitário.
Williams argumenta que, se você é
um utilitarista comprometido,
e você acha que a coisa
moralmente certa
para Jim fazer é atirar em
1 e libertar 19,
então você não deve sentir
nenhum remorso ao fazer isso.
Há uma coisa bem clara a fazer.
O correto é matar 1 para salvar 19.
Você pode sentir a desaprovação moral
– na verdade, você deve sentir a
desaprovação moral –
em relação a Pedro, que
colocou Jim nesta situação.
Mas você não deve sentir
nenhuma desaprovação moral
em relação a Jim e, ainda mais
importante de acordo com Williams,
o próprio Jim não deve
sentir nenhum remorso.
Assim, entre os 77% de vocês
que responderam que Jim
faz a coisa certa ao
matar 1 e salvar 19,
vocês acham que ao atirar no
homem, Jim deve sentir alguma
repugnância, algum remorso em
fazer o que deve ser feito?
Ou vocês acham que Jim não deve
sentir nenhuma hesitação
em fazer o que para o utilitário, e para
vocês mesmos, é a coisa certa;
vocês acham que ele deve
sentir uma hesitação
como indicativo de algo
moralmente relevante?
Portanto, cerca de 70 de vocês devem
responder a esta questão.
Vamos ver os números que saem.
OK, então a maioria assumiu
apenas uma parte da imagem
consequencialista aqui,
pelo menos da maneira
entendida por Williams.
A maioria de vocês pensa que,
embora neste contexto
a coisa certa a fazer seja
matar 1 para salvar 19,
Jim não deve apoiar isso
de forma irrestrita
como a coisa certa a fazer.
Daqui a pouco, eu vou apresentar
uma analogia de Williams
para o caso de racismo residual para
tentar ajudá-los a ver por que
alguém que realmente leve em conta a
perspectiva consequencialista
acha que a combinação de
pontos de vista
apresentada pela maioria de vocês –
em que a coisa certa a fazer
é matar 1 para salvar 19, mas também
que a coisa certa a fazer é,
de algum modo, se sentir
mal por isso –
ainda não tem totalmente contemplada
o que a postura utilitária
oferece como uma forma de
compreender a moralidade.
Então, como vocês sabem,
Williams nos apresenta 2 casos.
O 1º é o que eu acabei de contar:
o caso de Jim e os índios presos.
O 2º é o caso de um típico
homem dos anos 1970
que está querendo voltar a trabalhar
porque é difícil ver a
esposa trabalhando fora.
Apresento isso como um filme de época.
Mas o trabalho que George
consegue, no exemplo de Williams,
é num laboratório de
armas biológicas,
algo a que George sente
oposição moral.
Mas se George não aceita o trabalho no
laboratório de armas biológicas,
uma pessoa muito mais entusiasta,
provavelmente um defensor do uso
das armas biológicas,
vai trabalhar no seu lugar.
Assim, os 2 casos que
Williams nos apresenta
têm uma estrutura comum.
E uma estrutura comum
que vamos encontrar repetidas
vezes em dilemas morais.
Há um ato que a pessoa pode fazer que
leva a um resultado particular;
um outro ato que a pessoa pode
fazer que leva a um resultado
diferente, onde o 1º ato é pior na
sua superfície que o 2º.
Portanto, Jim tem a
possibilidade de atirar em 1
pessoa
ou não atirar em ninguém.
Essas são as escolhas de Jim.
Se Jim opta pelo 1º ato,
disparando em 1 pessoa,
então 19 pessoas estão livres;
se Jim opta pelo 2º, que é
não atirar em ninguém,
recusando a proposta de Pedro,
em seguida, 20 pessoas serão fuziladas.
Da mesma forma, George enfrenta
uma escolha entre 2 coisas:
aceitar o emprego no
laboratório de biologia
ou não aceitar o emprego no
laboratório de biologia.
Se George assume o cargo
no laboratório,
então o entusiasta das armas
biológicas não vai conseguir
o emprego e o resultado será melhor.
Se George não aceita o trabalho,
então o entusiasta das armas
biológicas vai ficar com o cargo
e o resultado será pior.
Assim, em ambos os casos,
temos um ato de matar 1 contra
não matar ninguém,
assumir o cargo contra não
assumir o cargo;
um é pior que o outro, mas os
resultados desses atos são invertidos.
O consequencialista diz para não se
deter no ato da equação,
e sim no resultado da equação.
As únicas coisas, diz o
consequencialista,
que precisamos considerar
são quantas pessoas são salvas
ou quanta investigação de
armas biológicas é feita.
De acordo com o consequencialista,
o que fazemos é constatar
que o resultado 1
é melhor que o resultado 2 e, então,
a partir disso decidir o
que devemos fazer.
Nós devemos fazer o ato 1
porque é a única coisa que
produz o melhor resultado.
O deontologista ou o
ético da virtude diz:
Um momento...
Não pule direto para a consequência,
olhe também para o que é
necessário ser feito pelo indivíduo
para chegar a essa consequência.
E reconhecendo que ato 1 é
pior que o ato 2,
o deontologista ou ético
da virtude diz que,
no mínimo, é importante levar a
sério uma possibilidade
de que a coisa certa a fazer
nessa situação é o ato 2,
mesmo que o resultado
alcançado seja pior.
Agora, o que Williams ressalta é que,
ao levar a sério a 1ª postura,
aquela em que nos importa o resultado
e não o processo que deu
origem a esse resultado,
qualquer remorso sentido ao
trazer esse resultado
à tona como consequência
do ato particular
é por causa do que poderíamos chamar
de um certo tipo de escrúpulo.
O utilitarista diz,
e por esse motivo nós começamos
com as citações de Mill,
que pensar em quem realiza o ato
é moralmente irrelevante,
assim como é moralmente irrelevante
pensar em quem recebe o bem.
O que importa, diz o princípio
da maior felicidade,
é o quanto de bem-estar
total é produzido;
o que não importa, exceto na
medida em que afeta
a quantidade de bem-estar, é
quem produz o bem-estar
ou a quem se destina o bem-estar.
Portanto, há espaço na
imagem consequencialista
para pensamentos de 2ª ordem sobre as
distribuições do bem-estar.
Se as desigualdades mais gritantes
na quantidade de bem-estar
produzem menos bem-estar numa sociedade,
então podemos considerar
isso no nosso cálculo.
Se realizar um determinado tipo de ato
produz menos bem-estar num indivíduo,
podemos considerar isso no
nosso cálculo.
Mas, em última análise,
as únicas coisas que entram na
equação para determinar
se um ato é moralmente correto é
a quantidade de bem-estar,
e não onde é distribuído o bem-estar.
Agora, como Epicteto destacou,
algumas coisas estão sob o
nosso poder e outras não.
E quando Jim chega à aldeia,
uma das coisas que não está sob o
poder dele é o fato de se deparar
com uma escolha forçada da
estrutura apresentada por Pedro.
Isso sem dizer que o que
Pedro fez é ultrajante.
Mas a estrutura da
situação que Jim confronta
é uma forma muito simples.
Ou Pedro mata 20 pessoas
ou Jim mata 1 pessoa e
outras 19 não morrem.
Isso é o que está em pauta
para Jim decidir.
No entanto, 75% dos 75% de vocês
que pensavam que Jim fez a coisa
certa nessa situação
acham que Jim deve sentir algum
escrúpulo na realização de tal ato.
O que Williams ressalta é que, ao levar a
sério a imagem consequencialista,
então talvez a coisa moralmente certa
a fazer é tentar cultivar em si
mesmo os sentimentos morais
que estão de acordo com os
próprios julgamentos morais.
Se por meio da argumentação
racional e da reflexão
– apesar de estar comprometido
com a igualdade racial,
de estar comprometido com a
igualdade de gênero,
de estar empenhado em não
estereotipar as idades,
de estar empenhado em não discriminar com
base na deficiência física –
você pode se dar conta de que,
como resultado de viver
numa sociedade estruturada
em grande parte
de forma a codificar uma
espécie de racismo residual,
de sexismo e de homofobia,
você pode se encontrar em certos
sentimentos que o levam,
instantaneamente, respondendo
de maneiras contrárias
ao que os seus compromissos morais
dizem que você deve fazer.
Nesses casos,
incito a reflexão se existe
algum mandato moral
para você tentar se livrar
dessas respostas instintivas.
Se você está realmente comprometido
com a luta contra o racismo,
então você quer, na medida do
possível, ter uma alma harmoniosa
ao se envolver em
encontros interraciais.
Se a sua razão diz que você está
comprometido contra o racismo,
você quer que o seu espírito e apetite
estejam alinhados dessa forma.
Portanto, há casos em que a
moralidade na reflexão
nos diz que algo é certo e a
consequência disso
para o nosso comportamento em
relação a nós mesmos
é que devemos tentar cultivar
em nós mesmos instintos
que correspondam a isso.
Williams afirma que o
utilitário deve dizer
que em casos como o de Jim, Jim é
como o racista residual.
Ele sabe qual é a coisa certa a fazer,
mas ele tem uma tendência residual
a ser puxado para a direção
moralmente errada.
Se você não acha que Jim
deveria mudar as atitudes
dele neste caso e você acha que o
racismo implícito residual
deve tentar mudar a atitude,
seria útil tentar pensar
sobre o que separa esses 2 casos.
OK, então é isto o que eu
quero dizer ao encerrar
sobre utilitarismo e os seus críticos.
E nós vamos voltar, como eu disse,
com esses temas mais 2 vezes,
uma vez na quinta, na leitura do
artigo de Judy Thomson
sobre o problema do Trolley,
e outra na próxima terça,
quando analisarmos alguns trabalhos
empíricos sobre essa questão,
o que sugere uma
explicação naturalista
para a hesitação de Jim.
O que eu quero fazer agora é
apresentar a vocês
a 3ª das principais
perspectivas morais q
ue vamos considerar este semestre.
Então, na última aula
examinamos com cuidado
as teorias morais
consequencialistas de John Stuart
Mill,
as teorias que situam o valor moral de uma
ação nas suas consequências.
Na 1ª parte do curso
passamos muito tempo examinando a
teoria da virtude de Aristóteles,
que localizou o valor moral de
uma ação no ator.
Lembrem-se que observamos os
atos que têm valor moral
somente se eles são
feitos como resultado
de uma espécie de
constância de caráter.
Estamos entrando hoje na 3ª
parte da história,
de uma visão moral que afirma que a
moralidade ligada a uma ação
não é o resultado de como é o ator,
não é o resultado de como
são as consequências,
mas sim da ação em si.
Em especial, vamos examinar a teoria
deontológica de Immanuel Kant.
Portanto, Kant foi um filósofo
alemão do século 18 que,
assim como Platão e Aristóteles,
forneceu uma teoria filosófica
abrangente e sistemática que até
hoje é levada a sério c
omo uma das formas possíveis de dar
sentido ao mundo como um todo.
Kant tem teorias de metafísica, ou
seja, que tipo de coisas existe.
Ele tem teorias de
epistemologia, isto é,
como sabemos sobre que tipo
de coisas existe.
Ele tem teorias de ética, qual
é a coisa certa a fazer.
E ele tem teorias de estética, ou seja,
o que dá valor estético às coisas.
Kant articulou as suas opiniões
sobre esses 3 grandes domínios
da filosofia em 3 livros
enormes e densos:
o 1º, A Crítica da Razão Pura,
conta sobre como é o mundo e como o
conhecemos para ser assim,
escrito em 1781 e, em seguida, revisado;
o 2º, A Crítica da Razão Prática,
é um modelo da natureza da moralidade;
e o 3º, A Crítica do Juízo,
é um modelo da natureza do
valor estético.
Mas, além dessas obras densas,
Kant também escreveu
o que são exposições mais
populares sobre a sua opinião.
No caso da metafísica,
ele escreveu o livro Prolegômenos a
Toda a Metafísica Futura.
E no caso da ética,
ele escreveu algo chamado
Fundamentação da Metafísica dos
Costumes,
que é a obra à qual lemos
trechos para hoje.
Portanto, eu apresento este
contexto para que vocês saibam
que, ainda que a leitura de
Kant tenha sido dura,
eu escolhi, talvez, a parte mais fácil do
livro mais fácil que ele escreveu.
Então, o que vocês deveriam
levar para casa de Kant?
Se vocês não absorvido nada mais
da nossa leitura de Kant,
eu quero que vocês absorvam a ideia dele
sobre o imperativo categórico.
O meu objetivo no restante da aula
de hoje é conduzir vocês,
a partir da leitura do texto de Kant,
a um ponto em que estarão bem
situados para entender
o que Kant quer dizer com o
imperativo categórico.
E, dependendo de como serão os
próximos 20 minutos,
vamos chegar a isso no
final da aula de hoje
ou no início de quinta-feira.
OK, o texto de Kant...
A Fundamentação da
Metafísica dos Costumes
começa com uma passagem muito
famosa, onde Kant diz:
"nada é possível pensar que
possa ser considerado
como bom sem limitação a não ser uma
só coisa: uma boa vontade".
O pedido deve ser familiar para vocês,
leitores do Livro II de A
República de Platão.
Esta é a clássica distinção entre as
coisas que têm valor intrínseco
e as coisas que são meramente
de valor instrumental.
E, de fato, assim como faz o
Sócrates de Platão,
Kant passa a enumerar algumas coisas
que ocupam outra categoria,
a de coisas que são de mera
utilidade instrumental.
Entre as coisas que não
podem ser consideradas
como boas sem limitação, diz Kant,
estão os talentos da mente
como a inteligência e a argúcia,
qualidades do temperamento
como a coragem e a perseverança,
dons da fortuna como o poder,
riquezas, honra e saúde.
E ele diz, fazendo pouco
caso de Aristóteles
– e fazendo isso de propósito...
Oh, meu Deus, como é que eu
fecho este e-mail?...
que nem as antigas
virtudes da moderação
e do autocontrole podem ser
consideradas como boas em si mesmas.
Por quê? Porque embora ser
inteligente, corajoso, rico
ou controlado ajude você a
alcançar os objetivos propostos,
eles não determinam quais
são esses objetivos.
Eles ampliam a sua
eficácia como um agente,
mas não determinam a valência,
o valor da sua agência.
Kant afirma que um ladrão astuto,
perseverante, rico, saudável
e moderado será um excelente ladrão...
mas isso não faz com que o seu
dom de roubar seja bom.
Cada uma das virtudes que
tradicionalmente tem sido exaltada
como uma virtude, diz Kant,
ganha o seu valor apenas
na medida em que a boa
vontade faz parte dela.
Uma boa vontade, diz Kant, é boa
não por causa do que ela afeta
ou realiza, ela é boa em si mesma.
Quando eu digo que Kant é um
crítico do consequencialismo
não estou exagerando.
Kant não acha que o resultado
do ato é o que importa.
E numa passagem muito famosa,
em parte por causa da tradução
[menciona a versão em inglês],
Kant diz que a boa vontade
permaneceria boa
"mesmo que por um desfavor
especial do destino,
ou pelo apetrechamento avaro
duma natureza madrasta,
faltasse totalmente a esta boa vontade
o poder de fazer vencer as
suas intenções".
Ele quer dizer que mesmo que
você com a sua boa vontade
fossem frustrados em todos os objetivos
que você se propõe atingir,
as suas ações ainda
teriam valor moral.
E de forma mais poética e com um
pouco menos do vocabulário
que desafia os ouvidos
modernos, Kant diz que,
mesmo que não isso não atinja os
seus resultados a boa vontade
"ficaria brilhando por si
mesma como um joia,
como alguma coisa que em si mesma
tem o seu pleno valor.
A utilidade ou a inutilidade nada podem
acrescentar ou tirar a este valor".
E a pergunta agora é esta:
Como alguém poderia vir a ter
esse ponto de vista?
Como alguém poderia ter uma
opinião da moralidade que diz
que o que importa para um ato ser moral
não é o resultado que ele produz,
mas a descrição sob a
qual o ato é feito?
O que eu quero tentar fazer
agora é posicionar vocês
dentro da imagem kantiana
para que vocês tenham
uma noção do que essa visão
de mundo se parece.
Assim, nas passagens lidas,
Kant faz 3 alegações particulares.
Ele diz que, para ter valor moral,
uma ação deve ser feita a
partir do dever.
A 1ª noção que eu quero
tentar explicar
é a noção kantiana de algo que está
sendo feito a partir do dever.
Uma ação feita a partir do dever, diz
Kant na sua 2ª proposição,
tem o seu valor moral não no propósito
que deve ser atingido por ela,
mas na máxima segundo a qual a
ação é determinada.
Portanto, a maneira que uma ação
executada a partir do dever
tem valor moral não está enfocada no
resultado que você espera dele,
e sim sob qual caracterização
você executou a ação.
E, mais uma vez, vou esclarecer
o que cada um desses termos significam.
Finalmente, diz Kant, o dever
– que está no cerne da teoria
moral deontológica –
"é a necessidade de uma ação
por respeito à lei".
Kant acredita que apenas
quando você sujeita
a sua vontade a uma lei que
você fez para você mesmo
– ou seja, a lei moral cuja
força obrigatória
sobre você foi
reconhecida por você –,
somente nessa circunstância, você
é verdadeiramente livre.
Assim, Kant diz:
"Dever é a necessidade de uma
ação por respeito à lei"
e quando você executa uma ação
por respeito à lei moral,
diz Kant, então, e só então,
você age de forma autônoma.
OK, portanto 3 alegações sutis e
extremamente complicadas de Kant.
Vamos tentar chegar ao fundo
dos seus significados.
Vamos começar com a 1ª,
a afirmação de que um
ato tem valor moral
somente quando é feito a
partir do dever.
Kant aponta que existem 3
tipos de motivação
que podemos ter na
realização de um ato.
Podemos realizar um ato por dever,
por inclinação
ou por interesse próprio.
Apenas casos do 1º tipo, na verdade,
apenas casos puros do 1º
tipo, têm valor moral.
Ações que são feitas
apenas em conformidade,
mas não por causa do dever moral,
não têm valor moral para Kant.
Então, se você obedecer a lei, mas
sendo apenas por interesse próprio,
a sua obediência, diz Kant, não
tem nenhum valor moral.
Se você resgatar a criança
que se afoga na lagoa,
mas só porque há uma placa
na árvore dizendo:
"Resgate por afogamento:
Recompensa de US$ 1 milhão",
o seu ato não tem valor moral.
Então podemos pensar sobre a
abrangência da alegação de Kant
e como ela diverge das demais examinadas
ao refletir sobre a questão nos
termos de um fluxograma.
Nós estamos tentando decidir se uma
determinada ação tem valor moral
e a 1ª coisa que queremos perguntar é:
Será que a ação concorda com o dever?
Se a resposta é não, ou seja,
se você fizer algo como mentir,
roubar, matar alguém
ou permitir que alguma coisa
terrível aconteça na sua frente,
que você podia ter evitado facilmente,
sem nenhum custo para você,
todos os autores que lemos,
sem surpresa, dizem que o ato
não tem valor moral.
Oh, isso tinha de desaparecer?
Isso era para ser em vermelho no preto?
É possível ver alguma coisa
aí na parte de trás?
Oh, isso é uma pena...
OK, o que diz em vermelho é não
mentir e roubar... mas em vermelho.
Eu não posso mudar isso no
meio dos slides,
mas vou lendo o que essas coisas dizem.
OK. A 2ª pergunta que fazemos...
tendo eliminado do reino do
moralmente digno
aquelas ações que não estão em
conformidade com o dever...
é a seguinte: Com qual motivo
o ato foi realizado?
Talvez você aja de uma
forma moralmente digna
por interesse próprio, sem
inclinações imediatas.
Você paga os seus impostos,
porque se você não pagá-los você
vai ter de pagar mais impostos.
Você obedece o limite de velocidade,
mas só porque você tem
medo de ser pego.
Mill diz que esses atos
têm valor moral.
Kant diz que não, eles não
... e, de novo, isso tinha de estar em
vermelho, mas está invisível...
Vamos supor que você execute
um ato de tal modo
que a sua inclinação esteja em
conformidade com o dever.
Portanto, Kant pensa que você tem o
dever de não cometer suicídio
e ele considera que você não comete
suicídio porque você está feliz.
Kant pensa que você precisa ser
fiel ao seu companheiro,
mas ele diz que não há nenhum valor
moral em ser fiel ao seu companheiro
enquanto você está apaixonado.
Não há nenhum valor moral, diz Kant,
em agir de forma gentil com alguém
quando você sente simpatia por ela.
Porque nesses casos, embora o seu
ato esteja em conformidade
com o que a moralidade exige,
ele não é feito porque é a
coisa certa a fazer.
Você o executa porque a sua
inclinação se alinha
com o que a moralidade exige de você.
Aristóteles, é claro, pegou essa
situação para ser a única em que
o valor moral é
paradigmaticamente
expresso.
Mas Kant pensa que, nesses casos,
você não pode dizer que um ato foi
feito por causa da lei moral.
Você pode ver que ele foi feito
de acordo com a lei moral,
que ele corresponde com as
exigências das leis morais,
mas não podemos ver com isso
que o motivo era o dever.
É somente no 3º caso, em que
você age a partir do dever
sem qualquer inclinação e sem
qualquer interesse próprio,
que Kant pensa que pode ser visto o
valor moral de uma ação.
Se você preservar a sua vida
quando sentir inclinação
para fazer o contrário,
se você agir forma gentil em
situações onde não há recompensa
e você não sentir nenhuma simpatia,
nesses casos, diz Kant,
podemos ver que o ato foi feito, não
apenas em conformidade com,
mas por causa da lei moral.
Isso não quer dizer que Kant não
pense que uma vida vivida
do jeito que se vive a vida sugerida por
Aristóteles seja uma vida ruim...
Os casos em que a sua inclinação
atua para alinhar com o dever
ajudam a manter você fora desta
caixa de fazer a coisa errada,
mas eles não permitem que
você teste o seu caráter
e veja de você mesmo
que a motivação que você tem
para fazer a coisa certa
está em conformidade com o que a
lei moral exige de você.
Assim, com esse entendimento do que
é agir por causa do dever,
agora estamos em condições de dar
sentido à 2ª afirmação de Kant
da nossa leitura de hoje.
Portanto: "Uma ação praticada por
dever tem o seu valor moral,
não no propósito que com
ela se quer atingir,
mas na máxima que a determina".
Lembrem-se que aprendemos que uma
ação feita por causa do dever
é aquela que você faz em conformidade
com a exigência da moralidade,
porque é isso que exige a moralidade.
Não porque é do seu
interesse próprio,
não porque você estava inclinado a
se comportar desse jeito,
mas porque esse ato é o que a
moralidade exige de você.
Mas, a fim de determinar se um ato é o
que a moralidade exige de você,
esse ato deve ser descrito de uma
maneira particular para você.
E o modo que você descreve
esse ato para você mesmo
utiliza o que Kant chama de máxima
– um princípio subjetivo do querer;
ou seja, uma descrição de algo
sobre você, o indivíduo,
que conta quais são os seus
desejos relacionados
ao comportamento nessa situação.
O princípio subjetivo do
querer, ou seja,
uma descrição em que o
ato foi celebrado.
Ele toma forma talvez:
"Em todos os envolvimentos com todos
os que entram na minha loja,
vou proporcionar uma contabilidade
honesta de quanto vale a transação,
independentemente de se eu posso ser
descoberto trapaceando nisso."
Ou: "Em todos os meus encontros
com aqueles que são fracos
e precisam da minha ajuda, vou
ajudá-los no que eu puder,
independentemente se isso será
um benefício para mim."
"Considerar somente o motivo, sem
considerar o resultado,
pode ser a ação expressiva da
boa vontade em si mesma."
"A boa vontade é a única coisa que
é boa em si mesma", diz Kant,
e só quando analisamos a descrição
em que um ato é realizado
é que podemos determinar se a
boa vontade foi implicada
no caminho certo na escolha de
executar uma ação.
3ª proposição:
"Dever é a necessidade de uma
ação por respeito à lei."
Portanto, sabemos que um
ato tem valor moral
apenas se ele é feito por
causa do dever.
Sabemos que a fim de ser feito
por causa do dever,
ele precisa ser feito sob uma
certa descrição.
E agora nos foi dito o que é
equivale a esse dever.
Para que um ato seja feito
por causa do dever,
ele deve ser feito com o
reconhecimento explícito
de que o que se está fazendo nesse
momento é respeitar a lei moral,
na medida em que ela articula o que a
moralidade exige de você.
Não na medida em que ela
articula maneiras
de você poder ter uma alma feliz,
harmoniosa e bem-ordenada.
Não na medida em que ela articula
formas pelas quais muita felicidade
possa ser espalhada para muita gente.
E sim por respeito
ao fato de que isso é o que a
moralidade exige de você.
O valor moral de um ato, diz Kant,
não está no seu efeito;
pelo efeito, poderia ter
surgido de várias maneiras.
Eu posso liberar um gás
biológico no metrô
com a intenção de matar
milhares de pessoas,
mas por não ser muito boa em química,
o resultado poderia ser a produção
de uma grande quantidade de alegria
naquelas milhares de pessoas.
O efeito pode ocorrer de
muitas maneiras.
Kant aponta que Mill diria
que ao liberar o gás
eu fiz algo com valor moral.
Kant ressalta: Não...
O que importa é a descrição
sob o qual o ato é feito,
e, em especial, que essa descrição
seja a que respeite a própria lei.
Portanto, eu disse que chegaria ao
ponto do imperativo categórico
e vou encerrar a aula de
hoje justamente aqui.
Vamos falar sobre isso com mais
detalhes na próxima aula.
A questão é esta, não é?
Esta é uma questão
emocionante e premente em Kant.
Tudo bem, eu sei que estamos
no momento kantiano,
mas isso é realmente emocionante.
"Mas que lei…", diz Kant.
Ele coloca um "mas" para
aumentar a emoção.
Ele diz... suspense…:
"Mas que lei pode ser então
essa, cuja representação,
mesmo sem tomar em consideração o
efeito que dela se espera,
tem de determinar a vontade para
que esta se possa chamar boa
absolutamente e sem restrição?"
É tão emocionante!
Estamos descobrindo algo que nos
tornará realmente autônomos,
livres e morais!
Bem, lembrem-se: isso não pode ser
qualquer coisa particular,
não pode ser qualquer coisa
específica sobre o mundo
ou os seus resultados.
O que pode ser?
Pode ser a conformidade universal
da vontade de suas ações
para a lei como tal!
Ou seja, o que faz que a lei
seja obrigatória
é o fato de que ela seja reconhecida
por todos os agentes racionais como tal.
Em especial, ela assume a
forma que Kant chama
de imperativo categórico.
E aqui está a formulação do
imperativo categórico
que vimos na leitura para hoje:
"Devo proceder sempre de
maneira que eu possa querer
também que a minha máxima se
torne uma lei universal."
Nunca faça nada
que você não queira que as
outras pessoas façam.
E nós vamos começar a próxima aula
com o exemplo que Kant utiliza para
ilustrar essa situação
– em especial a falsa promessa –,
falar mais sobre as
várias formulações
do imperativo categórico e depois
passar para o artigo de Judy
Thomson e o dilema do Trolley.